so chat warum coconert ihr mich? was ist der anlass?
exellent so sehr gut also
den kram nochmal anmachen ich weiß ja ob ich die vm brauche ehrlich gesagt muss man mal gucken
ja es gibt doch nichts besonderes also ich habe jetzt nichts mehr vor den letzten eineinhalb
stunden hier großartig neues anzufangen zähle euch mal ein paar sachen die so aufgefallen sind
kram vm anschmeiß noch mal chat aufmachen meine neue tastatur ist heute angekommen leider
musste ich jetzt nach elf monaten neue tastatur bestellen weil weil die in den geisthof gegeben
hat nach elf monaten eigentlich totaler witz ja controltaste war schon länger im arsch aber
jetzt ist nicht nur die deck dieses keycap ding abgegangen sondern der schalter geht auch
immer richtig nach elf monaten überlegt euch das mal was ein kack die ollen ibm tastatur
150 jahre gehalten ja also ich weiß nicht aber ansonsten gefällt mir dass die tastatur wirklich
gut also bringt ja alles nichts wenn sie kaputt geht ne kannst du kurz die ergebnisse vom performance
bei deinem videoprojekt sagen ja kann ich das so wie ich brauche ich habe bisschen kacke
programmiert das hat nicht so gut funktioniert es gegen maximal 30 verbindung gleichzeitig das
reicht macht kaum einer irgendwie 30 streams von dem raspberry pi auf aber ich weiß nämlich von
der von den versuchen nicht gemacht haben dass das viel viel mehr geht und ich weiß jetzt auch woran
das gelegen hat ich mache den ganzen kram hier von gestern mal zu weiß jetzt auch woran das gelegen
hat woran hat es ja noch mal gelegen also ich habe es gefixt aber woran woran hat es noch mal
gelegen ich habe genau ich habe auf der einen seite habe ich im camera thread irgendwelche
dinger gemacht das war das eine blöde und und dann habe ich noch was war dann das problem
ich weiß es kann ich mir genau ich glaube ich glaube ich habe zu viele frames weg geworfen
an obwohl ich lieber hätte die buffern soll ich krieg gar nicht mehr zusammen ich habe
jetzt zumindest so gemacht dass ich ich ich zeige es euch in einem der nächsten steams
aber also ich kriege jetzt mit ach und krach 150 video streams vom raspberry pi durch dann
fängt es aber auch schon ordentlich an zu ruckeln aber niemand braucht 150 video streams von
raspberry pi tribulon zwölf monate exquisite subscription hier massiv massive huge moment wo ist es aber
moment die lautstärke ist nicht richtig die lautstärke ist zu leise und die kirby musik
ist geradezu ätzend und jetzt muss ich mir da muss ich mir was anderes geben gestern
geht nicht es geht halbwegs doch mal ein strebel und dankeschön subscription ja 150 150 streams
sind aber braucht kein mensch und dann ruckelts außerdem auch schon ein bisschen aber 150
video streams von raspberry pi sind glaube ich gar nicht mal so schlecht also ist er aber
auch voll am anschlag und wenn der garbage collector mal läuft dann ist ruckel ruckel
ruckel ruckel ruckel ansonsten geht es halbwegs ja ich könnte übrigens das andere zeug auch
noch was ich da programmiert ein bisschen optimieren wann der die ressourcen frei gibt
dass ich erst gar nicht garbage collecten muss aber scheiß drauf geht bin ich zufrieden
mit ja übrigens ich habe jetzt die led leiste in betrieb genommen die wir gestern zusammengeschraubt
haben wer es noch nicht gesehen hat auf twitter ich habe das mal gepostet guckt mal hier
richtig nice kann ich selbst feuerwerk machen sollte es dieses jahr kein feuerwerk geben
doch cool oder und wer genau guckt wird feststellen irgendwo liege ich mich wieder guck da da ist
mein arm und die kamera das sieht doch cool aus oder übrigens die die elektriker unter
euch die müssen wir mal was erklären ich habe mir dieses netzteil hier für die led strips
gekauft irgendwie so ein ding hier und das hat 5 volt 10 ampere das heißt maximal 50
watt wie kann es denn sein dass wenn ich den led strip auf komplett weiß stelle volle pulle
weiß der 63 63 watt braucht wie geht das gut vielleicht ist vielleicht packt das einfach
mehr als drauf steht da ist normal bei solchen netzteilen mehr also ich habe da ich habe da
um das um das zu messen was der macht habe ich das hier habe ich das benutzt ja so ein
ding so ein teil da habe ich drauf geguckt was es braucht also um nicht ich habe das um
gestellt da waren da meist 63 63 watt braucht es lustigerweise ich habe jetzt den gleichen
led strip den gleichen led strip angeschlossen an der anderen steckdose also an so einer
koge steckleis steckdosen leiste ja und wenn ich den hier den ihr jetzt da grad seht komplett
auf weiß stelle dann brauche plus 53 watt oder 52 oder 54 sehr sehr merkwürdig muss
man nicht verstehen oder das hier unten habe ich übrigens mittlerweile gefixt dass er hier
halt noch rein läuft in den led strip ich musste einfach offset einstellen das stimmt aber
ich habe das gleiche netzteil ja benutzt da sollte auch ungefähr das gleiche rauskommen
beim gleichen strip oder sagen wir so bei zwei unterschiedlichen strips gleicher bauart
hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht naja das ist nice ne was kennst du die hand of god
aus deinen trends was für ein ding ach das ist doch irgendein fußball kram oder es hat
jetzt noch irgendein fußball fußball mensch gestorben habe ich freund freund irgendwie so nebenbei mitgekriegt
fußball ist mir nicht wurscht nico schreibt hast mich inspiriert habe jetzt auch alles dafür
bestellt gibt es einen grund eher zum esp 32 als zum esp 2866 zugreifen
naja ja der preisliche unterschied ist quasi ja kaum kaum existent was kosten so eine note
mcu aktuell offen auf amazon das doppelte zweieinhalbfache von aliexpress ok excellent
also kostet 48 und esp 266 kostet 599 naja der unterschied ist ja wirklich kaum da also
die die 250 und die 150 da unterschied oder die die die 250 unterschied die macht es jetzt
nicht fett moment ich kann nicht rechnen was 599 auf 3 55 also die machen sie wirklich nicht fett
genau mittlerweile habe ich ja mittlerweile habe ich ja vier led strips
ach stimmt das sind ja fast sechs oder mehr 250 mal richtig quickmaps
so und da würde ich die esp 236 nehmen hast mehr pins und hast schnelleren rechner
und ja der in der regelfunktion der esp 236 einfach runter finde ich so wollte ich euch
jetzt kurz kurz zeigen ich habe jetzt ich habe zwei led leisten am start ich habe einmal eine
ws 2812 b in schwarz und in weiß übrigens heute hier gleich gleich startet black friday
huge black try hard 7 friday startet wisst ihr was mich wundert dass noch keiner gesagt hat
black friday black was auch immer wie und alles das wäre rassistisch weil es ist ja black und
wir wissen ja dass wenn weiße leute das wort black verwenden muss das ja prinzipiell eigentlich
fast immer rassistisch sein also warum ist da noch keiner auf die idee kommen und zu sagen
black friday friday ich bin offended oder black friday muss gebannt werden ok ich gebe zu ich
sollte keinen auf die ich sollte keinen auf die idee bringen das ist keine gute idee was
die leute auf idee bringt dann ist morgen der erste am start macht den twitter empörungs post
bei euch auf der arme mich wer frohe weihnachten gesagt sondern frohe winterzeit ich bin der
meinung man sollte es einfach jedem jedem freistellen was er ob er das sagen möchte oder nicht weil
gehört nicht auch irgendwie zu wie soll ich sagen so zu zu toleranz freiheit und und offenheit dazu
dass man das einem zugesteht wenn der frohe weihnachten sagen will dass der frohe weihnachten
sagt ich mein muss ja keiner sollte da keiner zu zwingen oder so aber wenn jetzt einer sich
auf weihnachten freut und die andere auch auf weihnachten freut aber warum nicht da kann
es auch echt übertreiben ja das ist halt übrigens die und jetzt sagen ich bin übelst müde schon
bin übelst müde und vergesslich gerade ich weiß ich ich wollte ich wollte kann auch was
ganz was anderes wollte ich gerade sagen leute wisst ihr eigentlich dass das habe ich vergessen
dass das liegt das liegt dabei wenn man so vor so auf halb acht vom rechner hängt und schon
kurz vorm pennen ist ja dann das ist vorbei
hast du dir ein lambo geholt ich habe immer noch ein billig opel agila also geld für
autos ausgehen würde ich würde ich nicht ja also komm mal zu was anderem was wollte ich
euch denn gerade sagen kann ich also was habe ich was habe ich denn gesagt lass mal überlegen
was habe ich gesagt also ich habe gesagt man soll es jedem freistellen mit frohe weihnachten
oder nicht und dann ist nicht ich muss jetzt mal den chat gucken ob ich der chat der chat
jetzt wieder dran erinnert bei uns in der firma ist es eh so ich verdrück mich da immer
wenn so weihnachten geht nicht dass ich auf die weihnachtsfeier muss oder so naja gut
scheiß drauf so also übrigens letztens hat mich doch einer im stream gefragt ein paar
ich weiß nicht mehr genau zumindest einer das habe ich mir gemerkt welche welche steckdosen
leiste ich jetzt für das verwendet habe wo ich hier letztens geflasht habe und so weil
ich doch weil ich doch also nein wo ich hier letztens gelötet habe im stream gestern war
was ist letztens gestern gestern gelötet habe im stream da hat mich jemand gefragt
dem chat was das für eine leiste war die sich jetzt hat flaschen lassen das war die hier
die musste ich mir ja bestellen weil der chat gesagt hat max bestell dir die und die lässt
sich easy flaschen also muss sagen diese gosund typen nehmen es nicht so ernst mit firmen
wie updates die kannst du immer flaschen was sich nicht flaschen lässt ist was sich nicht
flaschen lässt ist ihr die da die hatte ich mir auch vor einer weile geholt die kannst
du kannst du voll vergessen kannst du komplett knicken das ding zu flaschen ich habe das
heut moin ich habe das heut moin aufgeschraubt weil es nicht flaschbar war aufgeschraubt
dran gelötet meiner meinung nach alles richtig gemacht ja auch von den pins her ich habe
da bestimmt vier stunden rumgemacht insgesamt es hat sich nicht flaschen lassen jetzt habe
ich die in die ecke geschmissen ich mache da nichts mehr dran vielleicht gibt es mal
irgendwann einen tuja convert bug dass man die doch noch flaschen kann oder so echt kill
fill hast du auch probiert also ich habe alles angelötet an dem ding komplett so wie es
sein muss und er hat einfach esp tool nicht connectet ich habe ich habe also kill fill
nur mal so ich habe ich habe die leiste hat gerade geplinkt warum macht die denn sowas
ja also ich habe eigentlich habe 3,3 volt dran kronn dran gehabt rxtx habe ich auch mal
gedreht und probiert und gpio 0 musste man ja hinten auf dem pin löten killfell habe
ich auch gemacht an kronn und das ding hat keine connection gekriegt so als hätten es
die chinesen kaputt gemacht beim einbauen absichtlich so genau also stimmt jetzt jetzt
weiß ich wieder was ich euch zeigen wollte und zwar also ich habe mir also ich habe ja
was wir gestern probiert haben diese led leisten und dann habe ich noch andere led leisten
gekauft aber die sind mir zu schade fürs fenster und zwar anzeige ich es raus led 9 sk 6 war
ich glaube ich glaube die von habe ich auch noch zwei gekauft eine schwarze und weiße
weil die haben rotgrün-blau led und eine weiße led also das ist rgbw damit kriegt man
viel schöneren weiß ton hin ok killfell moin captain seaguy also damit kriegt man viel
schöneren weiß ton hin aber ich glaube das werde ich mir ans bett machen also der eigentliche
sinn ist ja dass ich die led leisten ans bett mache ich habe mir jetzt übrigens mal auf
anraten des chats da noch so ein sortiment bestellt mit den klemmdingern dass ich für
jeden zweck eine ordentliche klemme habe hast du es auf irgendein produkt abgesehen
für black friday nö steht da jetzt schon was kommt upcoming oder so ganz ehrlich da
ist eh zum größten teil zu 90 prozent crap ach was zu 99 prozent ist da crap und ich
habe hier so eine theorie warum es das gibt warum so viel müll gibt auf amazon in diesen
cells meine theorie ist umso mehr müll es gibt und umso länger sich jemand hier durch
wühlt hd fire das sind eine eines der sachen die tatsächlich gehen weil es von amazon
selbst ist also umso mehr dieser crap deals es hier gibt und umso länger sich leute hier
durch wühlen wenn sie dann was gefunden haben was ihnen halbwegs gefällt dann ist die chance
höher dass sie es kaufen weil sie haben sich ja schon so angestrengt durch zu wühlen ich
weiß nicht ob das stonks theorie ist aber ich finde das klingt plausibel turex gachi
base hyper gachi sind das hier nee ich habe es auf nix abgesehen es juckt mich auch juckt
mich auch nicht nicht wirklich wenn ich was sehe kaufe ich ansonsten ist gut aber captain
pengen also wenn du wenn du wenn du esp 32 willst ich meine du wirst bei amazon nie billiger
kriegen als bali express das kannst du einfach net toppen für teilweise 350 oder so den
controller ja easy kannst du einen 4k tv empfehlen nein aber ja also ich habe ich habe ich habe
ich habe ein frag mich nicht sony kd 5 5 ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was ich für
einen hab irgendwie so ein habe ich man sieht ja hier diese so alt foto alter wo ich den
kaboom zusammenbettel viel drei spiele das ist ja uralt guck mal hier von 2012 lul we
lustig dass ich das jetzt gerade finde bei diesem post sollte man raten wer ich bin spoiler
ich bin der da da hatte ich noch so viele haare alter ich habe viel weniger haare seitdem
hier hatte ich noch keine hier hatte ich noch keine lücken auf dem kopf oder doch ich hatte
schon lücken aber nicht so viele lücken das war ein zahl in der wohnzimmer setup warum
ist da einfach habe ich eigentlich mal katz hier wo habe ich denn mal wohnzimmer setup
wieder also ich habe diesen fernsee aber warum findet der das denn nicht das video hier wohnzimmer
ich habe es noch wohnzimmer setup genannt hier ist es doch also ich weiß nicht ob man
nicht ob da irgendwo drauf steht was das für ein fernseh ist aber den habe ich jetzt auch
schon seit zwei drei jahren oder so hier so drei jahre ungefähr der ist wirklich nicht
verkehrt weil natürlich gibt es jetzt schon das oh leak das 20 nachfolge modell oder so
das ist auch ein 4k fernseh auch wenn ich den hier gerade auf 1800p stehen habe also
die sony dinger sind eigentlich ganz nice die dinger katz leider habe ich das in so
kacke quali fotografiert ja also kann da knicken das ding hier ja ist ewig her ne ja das ist
viel haare überlegt ihr mal wenn das viel haare ist enjoy tv auf dem schild tv schild
tv ist top kann es ja echt nicht sagen da gibt es nix das ding ist super snappy und
schnell alles echt gut ne ne ne ne stripes das war 2.0 also ich hatte bisher seitdem wir
hier in dieser wohnung sind hatte ich drei katzen seit 2013 ich hatte die erste das
war die hier habe ich auch ein bild habe ich ein bild von meiner ersten katze die kennt
ihr die getigerte katz wartet mal ich habe ich habe aber hier irgendwo ein bild die hier
die hier das da das ist die erste die habe ich auch nicht aus dem tierheim geholt oder
so die ist vom nachbar gewesen der nachbar ist gestorben und die katz hat im danach nach
ein zwei wochen oder so hat die rum gemaut im hof oder habe ich ihr was zu essen rüber
geschmissen und dann bin ich über den zahn geklettert war ja keiner mehr da dann bin
ich über den zahn geklettert und habe sie geholt rüber und dann ist die uns bestimmt
eine woche nicht mehr von der seite gewichen weil die hat schiss gehabt dass wir sie wieder
rausschmeißen so das war die erste die war aber schon alt die war dann 14 oder so also
die war schon ziemlich alt danach hatte ich die hier danach hatte ich die hier die habe
ich die hatte ich aus dem tierheim man wusste es nicht so genau als ich die aus dem tierheim
geholt habe aber die war da schon nicht so gesund weil normalerweise musste musste im
tierheim so so muss ein bisschen was bezahlen für die katze das machen die im tierheim
zumindest in dem tierheim wo ich mal auch das ein bisschen kosten decken können und
dass nicht jeder random einfach eine katze holt ja und da haben sie gesagt hier die ist
krank und die geben sie mir auch unter ich was bezahlen muss ich habe ich habe im tierheim
trotzdem was gespendet so die ist leider nicht alt geworden dann die hatte ich die
habe ich geholt glaub im glaub irgendwann im februar oder so und die hat es dann glaube
nur bis bis september oder so gemacht die hatte die hatte das ist was wo die wo katzen
mit also zu 99,9 prozent sterben so das hatte sich irgendwo in polen oder so eingefangen
das ist jetzt kein polen diss die kam wirklich aus polen irgendwo ja genau so und jetzt habe
ich chico wo ist chico wo ist chico hier ist chico jetzt habe ich chico chico habe ich
jetzt auch schon seit zwei jahren oder so fast fast zwei eineinhalb jahren ein dreiviertel
jahren chico und chico geht es gut dies übrigens mittlerweile habe ich den eindruck dies noch
dicker als auf dem bild laut wage nicht wie alt chico ist jetzt glaube zehn
ich glaube chico ist jetzt zehn ich habe nur alte katzen ich nehme immer alte katzen
weil keiner sonst alte katzen will und gerade bei alten katzen mal ernsthaft gerade bei
allen katzen will ich nicht dass die noch im tierheim sitzen noch irgendwie eins zwei
jahre und dann den löffel abgeben dann ist besser wenn die bei mir ein bisschen rum
stelsen dürfen noch so ja übrigens die katz hier ja das ist eine sie das ist also sie
heißt chico ich habe versucht das mit chica aber mit chica das mag sie nicht und ich vergesse
es auch immer aber das ist sie ich habe auch ich habe auch nur katzen ich habe alte katzen
wie es das alle oder ja und die hier chico hat übelst angst vor der led leiste ich habe
das hier vorhin aufgenommen habe ich euch ja gerade gezeigt ich habe das hier vorhin
aufgenommen und da ist die katz gerade durch den flur gelaufen alter hat die sich erschreckt
die hat ultra die hat ex die hat voll schiss gekriegt die ist zwei meter zurückgesprungen
abgehauen und dann habe ich sie dann habe ich sie unten gefunden im badezimmer das ist
quasi am anderen ende vom haus die hat total schiss von diesem ding und eben habe ich sie
auch mal auf den armen genommen wollte ihr zeigen und als das angefangen hat zu flimmern
musste man weg das konnte sich nicht konnte sich nicht geben also da hat die übelst panik
vor vielleicht fiept das ding mit nee das ja vielleicht aber ich glaube eher das liegt
an dem an dem geflimmer weil als es solid color war da ging nix da hat sie nicht großartig
interessiert aber als es geflimmern hat sie panik gekriegt bringt was auch witzig ist
wie unterschiedlich manche manche katzensinner die hier die hat total gerne fernsehe geguckt
der konnte ich dann teilweise da bin ich dann immer auf youtube gegangen habe so was hier
habe ich so was aufgemacht die eigentlich keiner eichhörnchen wiese oder park oder
so und das gibt es dann zehn stunden eichhörnchen videos für katzen der habe ich dann so was
hier angemacht die ist darauf abgegangen alter das habe ich dir angemacht und und da hattest
du teilweise hier sowas da und die dinger sind übelst groß hier auf dem fernsehturm
das habe ich drüben auf dem 4k 60 zoll 55 zoll fernseh fernseh gemacht sprich die dinger
waren auf dem fernseh so groß wie die katz ja aber die ist die ist die ist teilweise
verrat versucht die dinger zu fangen und sowas also die hat gesehen ok es ist verdoppelt
so groß wie ich aber sieht aus wie eichhörnchen jetzt wird es gefangen also die fand der fernseh
gucken ganz toll chico juckts überhaupt gar nicht chico ist aber eh ein bisschen ich will
ich sagen blöd aber chico ist eh ein bisschen hat eh ein wenig koalitionsprobleme die kann
auch sachen die die man wirft nicht richtig nicht richtig fangen also normalerweise wenn
ich hier bei wenn ich bei der baga wenn ich da ein bällchen geschmissen habe so ein flummi
oder so ey die ist da hinterher geflitzt ist gesprungen hat den flummi gefangen so
und chico und chico werfe ich den flummi entweder hat sie angst davor und haut ab wenn der flummi
zu groß ist 50 eq meets er so oder aber sie springt in die ganz falsche richtung also
ja so koordinationssachen ist nicht ihre stärke gestern ist gegen die tür gegen die tür gerannt
als ich beim striemen aus dem zimmer bin um hier den seitenschneider zu holen hat sie
gedacht wir machen jetzt spielen im flur und dann ist sie los geflitzt ins wohnzimmer und
die wohnzimmertür war nur so ein spalt auf und dann habe ich so richtig gehört so chico
rennt gegen die wohnzimmertür und durch ja also koordinationsmäßig hat es hat es
schicko nicht so ppz ja so machen wir mal zu hier also heute heute hat es mich übrigens
voll verwirrt ne ich hatte mir dieses ich hatte mir dieses netzteil hier gekauft für
die led leite für diese led leisten dieses teil und die ja die die leute die jetzt hier
im stream gesagt haben hier ich habe zu dünne kabel die hatten natürlich vollkommen recht
und das lag da dran es lag nicht nur an den kabeln ich habe ich hatte hier auch so ein
stecker zum anschließen oder mal ich zeige euch mal was ich meine ich mache jetzt einfach
mal kurz die passende sache von gestern im stream auf und da ist mir aufgefallen als
ich mir das dann noch mal angeguckt habe das war wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich auch das
problem oder mit das problem hier gibt es irgendwo diesen stecker dann max wo ist der
stream hier guck mal den da den stecker hier das ding hat die dünnsten kabel aller Zeiten
das hat 0,000001 mm oder sowas also intern hat dieser stecker quasi nicht existente kabel
deswegen ist das alles auch so heiß geworden das war total dünn das sind zwar nur 5 volt
aber das sind dann ja mindestens mal 10 ampere durch man zwar am ende 60 watt oder so also
das hat ordentlich ging ordentlich ab deswegen wurde auch der stecker so warm so und jetzt
habe ich das aufgeschnitten heute ich habe einfach den stecker abgemacht hier schnipp
schnapp und dann hatte ich ein problem das habe ich nämlich noch nie gesehen das sah
dann nicht so aus wie ich es erwartet habe ich habe es erwartet da sind zwei kabel drinnen
plus und minus ja das ist ein 5 volt dc 10 ampere ich habe ich habe erwartet da sind
zwei kabel drinnen plus minus hinter diesem holstecker wie heißt dieser stecker eigentlich
richtig so und jetzt passt mal auf wie das wirklich wie das dann auf einmal eben drin
ausgesehen hat irgendwie ein bild plus minus ja man erkennt es jetzt nicht so hier so sah
das da drinnen aus monka es was ist das denn da ist quasi in so ein kabel drinnen und
außen ist die umwandlung also sprich die umwandlung ist minus und innen drin das ist plus das
habe ich noch nie gesehen was ist das für eine komische konstruktion alter der control
hatte ich nicht und da wusste ich nicht was ich machen soll wie schließe ich das jetzt
an habe ich im endeffekt so gemacht hier dass ich das hier abgezweigt habe das hier wieder
die isolierung drüber gemacht habe schrumpfschlauch drüber gemacht habe und dann hier zwei klemmen
dran gemacht habe das funktioniert jetzt ganz gut und seit ich das gemacht habe ist auch
alles schön kühl keine stecker war nix also das lag wirklich unter anderem an diesem billigen
an diesem billigen zwischen stecker zwischen akku und leiste also der chat der chat war
wieder big brain der chat wusste wieder wo hast du das abgeschnitten hier da hier so
hier so also der erste habe ich da abgeschnitten und dann habe ich mir gedacht ha sieht komisch
aus dann habe ich hier noch mal abgeschnitten und das ist auch komisch aus so sah das halt
aus und aber das ist kein ding also es war wirklich easy im endeffekt man rollt das
hier auf rollt das hier auf das hier gibt es ja nicht macht hier den restlichen zeug
von der hülle noch mal drüber schrumpfschlauch drüber und dann passt das ganz gut dann in
eine klemme rein ja ging so genau ich habe gehört ich habe irgendwo gelesen chelly hat
neue dinge da müssen wir mal kurz gucken chelly hat angeblich neue dinger haben die
irgendwie die newsseite oder so new chelly den gehört das wo habe ich denn das gelesen
anscheinend doch nicht weil das kenne ich alles schon das ist jetzt nichts neues haben
irgendwie einen block oder so ja der 1l ist neu den habe ich mir auch schon in fünfer
pack bestellt heute kam hermes heute kam eine hermes mail ich vermute mal die chellys
sind das heute kam eine hermes mail das morgen zustellung ist ich wüsste nicht was es sonst
sein soll aber ich habe dachte ich habe gelesen die haben noch irgendwas anderes ja na gut
kurz was gucken
was ich auch nicht ganz verstehe ist ich habe mal nach wirklich richtig fetten netzteilen
geguckt die man auch wenn man mehrere led strips hintereinander verwendet oder so wofür
man was man nehmen kann ich habe man wenn man dann bei amazon guckt kann das 5 volt netzteil
oder wobei wahrscheinlich 12 volt netzteil besser ist und dann einfach konvertieren auf
5 an der stelle wo man es anschließt aber wenn man da mal nach sowas hier zum beispiel
guckt da findet man nur solche komischen china dinger was ich nicht verstehe ist das
nicht gefährlich wenn die dinger offen sind ich meine am gehäuse passiert nichts aber
die dinger liegen ja dann offen rum ein pc gehäuse ist auch ein pc netzteil ist auch
offen aber das ist ja im gehäuse drin und ich meine wenn du das ding hier einfach offen
rum liegen lässt und da fällt dann irgendwas rein oder so ist doch ziemlich kacke also
warum die alle offen sind verstehe ich nicht wie hast du denn die leds ans fenster geklebt
das ist ganz easy also man sieht ja hier die leds sind hier so um fenster drum herum das
ist ganz easy die led leisten haben klebeband oder doppelseitiges klebeband hinten schon
drauf wofür sollte das netzteil sein für led leisten also ich habe mal was geguckt
wo man halt auch mal ein bisschen mehr anschließen könnte und warum sind die offen ich verstehe
das nicht vor allem ich mache mir auch gar guck mal hier hinten machst ja dann den stecker
rein da kannst ja auch wenn du wenn du wenn du wenn du das doof stehen hast und dran greifst
bist du voll am kontakt dran ne das pritt das das habe ich auch gefunden das habe ich
auch gefunden desorption aber das ist auch nicht hat auch nicht viel mehr wums als das
andere netzteil was ich habe das hat nämlich auch nur 60w ich habe aktuell einen 50 volt
netzteil das macht es jetzt auch nicht fett kleines gehäuse weißt du wie lange mal an
so einem gehäuse druck dafür also die dinger sind jetzt ja auch nicht so klein was haben
die hier für abmaße naja wobei 20 mal 10 geht eigentlich so groß ist es gar nicht
ne ne die software habe ich nicht selbst programmiert ich habe meine weihnachtsbaumsteuer vor letztem
jahr selbst selbst programmiert das ist mir zu großer akt ich benutze das hier das hier
sp 32 gekauft für 350 das ding drauf geflasht und gut ist ja deswegen verstehe ich das nicht
ich bin doch nicht der einzige der damit leds betreibt da muss doch gehäuse für geben
deswegen der kühlung ok ich war es ist net sind alle offen mir wäre ja sowas sowas geschlossen
ist auch lieber sehr merkwürdig ach ja
ich habe mir jetzt noch oder ich glaube ich habe schon erzählt als ich mir das gekauft
habe aber ich habe es jetzt ausprobiert und zwar ich habe mir so eine ich habe mir so
ein teil hier gekauft bis sie billiger als 79 dollar ist eigentlich überlegt er mal
79 dollar für eine wlan klübirne also für nicht klübirne für eine wlan led lampe
ist eigentlich keck ich brauche prime subs aber was an der ganz cool ist die hat neben
dem ganz normalen led geben der ganz normal led rgb led geschichten hat die noch ein infrarot
led mit drin so und was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist ich habe sie ich habe das unten
in keller gelegt nicht in keller was laber ich heute für einen scheiß halte übelst
werden ins erdgeschoss gelegt und nachts ab 22 uhr geht das an und macht den ganzen flur
unten infrarot mäßig hell dass die kamera das sieht das heißt ich sehe jetzt sobald
die katze unten rum stellst im flur das ist die einzige ordentliche infrarot lampe die
ich gefunden habe die man wlan mäßig schalten kann ansonsten habe ich nur so ein kleines
kleines furzel zeug gefunden das ist die komplette jetzt ist der komplette flur unten
beleuchtet nachts halt halt infrarot beleuchtet so gelben sie keil sieben monat dankeschön
für den sub ja ja ja ja exzellent also und was ich mir zum ausprobieren mal bestellt
habe ist tatsächlich ich will ich will es gar nicht großartig benutzen eigentlich merkt
ich wähle die nach dem stromausfall in zustand ja was klang denn da dran falsch ich will
es gar nicht wirklich ausprobieren oder großartig verwenden ich habe mir mal zum zum einfach
nur weil es mich interessiert ob der kram funktioniert habe ich mir so ein komisches
fritz thermostat bestellt ich will einfach wissen ob dieser deck krempel funktioniert
weil ich bin mit dem ich bin mit meinem einen sigp thermostat nicht zufrieden das verliert
irgendwie batterie as fuck das hat das hat mit 70 prozent das hat mit 70 ich habe mir
mal zum test testen dieses ding hier gekauft da das ding aber auch nicht für den preis
sondern irgendwo für 29 oder sowas in dem dreh auch viel zu teuer eigentlich so und
das hat mit mit nach dem einbauen alles hatte 70 prozent batterie gehabt
ich habe keine ahnung was ihr meint ja und das hat mit 70 prozent batterie angefangen
und jetzt ist es runter auf 65 prozent batterie und das nach was drei wochen ja das hält
das hält keine ahnung 3 4 monate dann ist das leer
aber ich meine 5 prozent in drei wochen das ist ganz schön ganz schön viel oder in zwei
wochen weiß gar nicht genau das ist ja das ist ja gleich leer
das ist schon ganz schöner mist da mal lieber dann mal lieber irgendwas anderes weil was
bringt mir das hübscheste thermostat wenn es nach einem halben jahr oder nach vier
monat leer ist ich ich meine ist das das das wireless geräte mal irgendwann batterie leer
geht ist klar aber ich habe jetzt diese seawave fenster türen sensoren und die gehen jetzt
hot 3 ja und die funktionieren immer noch so und da kann es nicht sein dass diese komische
music beading direkt leer geht das darf nicht sein so habe ich irgendwas im chat übersehen
aber passi das mit dem gehäuse drucken ist eigentlich eine gute idee
was wo hast du das abgeschnitten nico was meinste ich habe nichts übersehen exzellent
so also zeit mal her also so lange bleibe ich heute garantiert nicht ordentlich bin übelst
kaputt ich weiß ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so genau warum wahrscheinlich zu viel rumgepasst
ich habe sogar noch ein bisschen aufgeräumt hier ich muss unbedingt leute wenn er das
bei mir im arbeitszimmer sehen könnte das ist echt das kannst du eigentlich keinem
zeigen das besteht hier zu einem drittel aus amazon kartons also in der ecke stand mal
eine kautsch all die siehst du kaum noch vor lauter amazon kartons es ist halbes lager
hier muss unbedingt mal die ganzen kartons wegschmeißen das zeugs ordentlich sortieren
kennt jemand wo wir gerade beim thema sind sortieren kennt jemand ein gutes inventar
management system gucken wir mal auf github ein gutes inventar management system software
github inventory management haben an da part key bei inventory wie viele bestellungen hast
du bei amazon schon ich guck mal ich muss auf dem handy gucken weil ich ansonsten nicht
drauf kommen wegen zwei faktor oder defizition ich kein bock hab das einzugeben guck mal aber
nachdem ich da schon seit 2003 oder 2 oder so bestellt habe ich wahrscheinlich auch schon
über 1000 aber wo sieht man das überhaupt wo sieht man welche amazon bestellungen man hat
your orders kann ich nur gucken filter also meine erste bestellung ist 2004 anscheinend
weiß gar nicht wo man sieht wie viel amazon bestellungen hat aber ich habe bestimmt locker
1000 ich habe locker 1000 wenn ich habe ja hier allein schon man kann es auch gar nicht nach
orders so aber wenn man mal nach einzelnen sachen geht die ich bei amazon bestellt habe
der zeigt hier nur sechs monate an so also ich zähle mal die einzelnen sachen und doppelte
items zähle ich nur einfach also 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 22
23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 39 40 42 43 44 45 46 47 48 59 50 51 52 53 54 55
57 58 59 60 61 22 33 44 55 66 67 68 99 70 71 72 73 74 75 76 77 78 79 80 81 82 83 84 85
86 87 88 89 90 91 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 ich habe 98 dinger bestellt aber nicht bestellung
sondern sondern items sachen die doppelt sind habe ich nicht mitgezählt also wenn
ich zwei stecker bestellt habe oder so dann dann habe ich da nur einmal irgendwie was
habe ich jetzt gesehen 98 ist also ungefähr 100 100 dinger in den letzten sechs monaten
bei amazon schon also selbst wenn das nur verteilt war über sagen wir mal keine ahnung
30 40 bestellungen dann habe ich dann 30 40 haben wir 40 80 im jahr 80 mal ja das ist
gar nicht so nicht dann komme ich das kann tatsächlich sein dass ich die 1000 noch gar
nicht voll hab guck mal da sind dann 80 bestellungen im jahr oder sagt man mal 100 bestellungen
im jahr vielleicht so und ich bin jetzt seit 2006 dabei da habe ich aber nicht so viel
bestellt machen wir nur mal 10 mal 10 100 das krieg ich im kopf auch noch hin also ja
doch wahrscheinlich bin ich bei 1000 bestellungen denke schon cat prey analyzer nee ich glaube
das kenne ich das ist das wo die mit der kameras gucken was die katze gefangen hat nein nein
meine fände keine mäuschen schicko und mäuse fangen schicko kann ja noch nicht mal irgendwelche
kabel richtig fangen ohne dabei gegen die tür zu rennen schicko schicko und mäuse
fangen also das wird im leben nix schicko liegt manchmal unten in der küche vor der
tür wo es zu den abflüssen geht und ich habe das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant und ich
hatte schon die vermutung dass vielleicht dort irgendwo entweder eine maus sogar drin
ist oder irgendwie bei den abflüssen in irgendwie eine maus rennt weil die findet das super
spannend und liegt da teilweise eine halbe stunde davor und lauert ich habe da aber noch
nichts gesehen an mäusen oder so aber katzen kriegen sowas hier instinktiv mit ich würde
zu gerne sehen wie schicko eine maus fängt also das würde ich das würde ich mir echt
unglaublich gerne angucken wie schicko eine maus fängt die dürfte sie fangen platt machen
ausbluten lassen was katz halt so macht mit mäusen ja das dürfte machen ich würde danach
sauber machen ich will sehen wie schicko eine maus fängt weil ich glaube die erwischt also
mich würde es wirklich extrem wundern wenn schicko die maus erwischt schicko ist so planlos
und und und koordinations fail katze und die kriegt das nicht gebacken so aber wo wir
hier gerade dabei waren kennt jemand kennt jemand gute gute inventar management systeme
aber wir haben noch eine frage im chat value of all orders gibt es da für irgendwas mit
irgendwie das in api oder so ist das auch das ist praktisch aber zu einer history reporter
total amount auch das ist das ist nett ich weiß bloß nicht ob ich so eine random extension
zugriff auf mein amazon account geben sollte also akenas fragt moin ich bin nicht so technik
versiert mal kurz den chat auf wieso brauchst du das weil ich mal wissen will wieviel ich
bei amazon bestellt habe wieviel geld ich schon gelatzt habe bei amazon bestimmt was
weiß ich 40.000 euro oder so ich habe schon alles möglich bei amazon bestellt von von
der vom wäschetrockner bis zum bis zur waschmaschine bis zum fernsee alles inwieweit inventar management
software ja wo ich meine ganzen bauteile die ich habe erfassen kann dass ich zum beispiel
reinschreibe also am liebsten würde ich reinschreiben hey 24 volt zu 5 volt converter schublade
eins schrank eins schublade eins so was nach dem motto so so was da könnte ich nämlich
volltextsuche machen in dieser inventarsoftware und da wüsste ich gleich wo ich meinen ganzen
krempel habe weil aktuell suche ich mich echt kaputt an manchen stellen barcode nee
ohne barcode hand eingeben die dinger haben kein barcode jetzt ärgere ich mich da ich
den kram nicht in der tüte gelassen hat mit barcode excess db ne excess db ist das jetzt
meinst du das ernst ich mach garantiert keine excess db also was hat er erklärt hier moin
ich bin nicht so technikversiert und vielleicht kann mir jemand weiterhelfen ich will mir
ein sata zu sp adapter holen um mein altes internet internes blu ray laufwerk extra nutzen
zu können brauche ich dafür eins mit extra netzkabel oder reicht die ich vermute mal
was brauchen so einen plu das ist eine gute frage was brauchen so eine blu ray laufwerk
an strom ich würde darauf tippen nach das ist laser kram aber ich weiß nicht was braucht
das denn ich würde darauf tippen man braucht einen extra man braucht den extra mittlerweile
kriegt man aus usb auch relativ viel strom raus ne ne ich will nicht dass irgendwie einer
was bastelt ich will auch nicht selbst basteln es gibt bestimmt fertige inventar management
systeme garantiert gibt es da fertige sachen snipe it ist nicht gut für den zweck das
habe ich schon ausprobiert das ist eher so eine surfer fünf steht in rekt zwei und so
das hat mir jetzt nicht so ich kann es mir noch mal gleich angucken mit einer demo ist
das eine gute idee das probieren wir gleich mal snipe in demo können wir gleich mal ausprobieren
also ich würde vielleicht ich würde jetzt aus bauch aus sagen du brauchst einen strom
kabel aber ich kann das wirklich nicht einschätzen netbox nein nein ich will meine surfer ich
will nicht meine surfer mit ip inventarisieren ich will meine hardware teile inventarisieren
was weiß ich dass das das sortiment mit widerständen ist in schrank 1 schublade 1 die was weiß
ich die die seitenschneider sind in schublade 2 die esp 32 tiny pico sind in schublade 3
sowas will ich haben dass ich einfach was mit volltext suche gucken kann vielleicht kennt
er da jemand was warum nicht selber na weil ich dass das selber machen muss und selber
supporten muss da habe ich keinen bock da ich will irgendwas fertiges haben wir gucken
jetzt mal was da gibt was ist denn das hier partkeeper 777 sterne klingt schon mal schlecht
java oder ist das nicht java das java frontend oder leute oder oder in alles php eins von
beinem ich vermute fast dass es java xjs ist es ok stimmt ja klar ist es xjs das ist das
gleiche wie tv headend was ist denn xjs eigentlich irgendwas altes oder ja 2007 excellent wie
das ausschaut schon wikipedia spendors
xjs ist was haben sie was hatten die da geritten dass man sowas verwenden soll das sieht aus
wie windows forms im web guckt euch das mal an geht das ist ja absolut absolut ist das
usability ist key ne wenn ich das sehe dann eher nicht ok also was haben wir als nächstes
inventory wie schaut das aus die haben erstmal die haben erstmal schon gar keine screenshots
die wissen dass kacke aussehen deswegen macht man da keine screenshots rein ich das verstehen
sie auch das verstehe ich ich verstehe nicht warum dass so viele projekte nicht verstehen
als allererstes wenn screenshot braucht wie der ganze krempel aussieht das ist das allerwichtigste
egal was für eine anwendung ist und wenn sie größte kacke anwendung ist wenn die screenshots
hast dann probieren sie leute aus gibt es davon eine demo andere probiere ich nicht aus
ja captain ck das mache ich genauso probierst du gar nicht aus also wir sollten es neid demo
das habe ich schon mal ausprobiert vor vor einer ganzen weile das hat mir nicht gefallen
das war eher sowas für was weiß ich das telefon steht bei dem typ auf dem platz oder server
xy steht dort das hat mir nicht so gefallen admin password
inventory inventory habe ich noch nie gehört was inventory kenne ich nicht
alter es wird ja immer schlimmer was frage könntest du mal versuchen mit
deinem pie dvbc signalpingel zu analysieren ich verwende kein raspberry pie für tv headend
oder was meinste das sieht nicht umsonst so aus wie piehall
das piehall verwendet irgendeinen 0815 admin dashboard das haben die nicht selbst gemacht
die wahrscheinlich auch so also was kann man jetzt hier machen dashboard
das ist etwas erscheint mir übermäßig komplex zu sein
license asset glaube das ist aufwag ich glaube das ist voll aufwag kill für meine zwecke
daheim ich brauche nichts grosses ich brauche ich brauche theoretisch noch nicht mal ein
richtiges inventarsystem ich brauche einfach eigentlich reicht mir ein notizprogramm mit
volltextsuche
gibt es gibt es solche dinge wo man den barcode scannt und der automatisch sich im internet
raussucht welcher barcode das ist wobei das kann er ja nicht wissen irgendwelche komischen
adapter von china hersteller da kann er den barcode ja nicht kennen excel nein nein ich
nehme kein excel ihr wisst ich habe kein also ich habe ich überhaupt office installiert
ja aber verwende ich verwende kein office produkte
das ich kann das nee das kann ich nicht richtig ausprobieren im raspberry pi ich habe kein
dvbc stick und das ist auch ein gebiet wo voll ich echt keinen plan habe
ich ok also wie legt man denn jetzt hier was an also was haben wir hier accessories ganz
consumables also ist das kompliziert warum haben die aids
eight new das ist mir viel zu overkill das ist mir viel zu overkill das ding create assets
so da müsste ich jetzt eingeben was weiß ich dicken sonn gachi bass asset tag serial
model kann man da drin kann man da drin überhaupt da kann man nicht mal volltextsuche machen
oder
kann man da volltextsuche drin machen sound
nee nee nee nee nee nee da krieg ich brauche ich brauche im prinzip nur volltextsuche
ich prokramier das nicht selbst ich will was fertiges haben
weil ich habe so viel kleinteile ich brauche langsam echt sowas hat das eine ordentliche
suche wenigstens hier eine suche suche ja ok das wäre das wäre tatsächlich brauchbar
ja in der tabelle würde das gehen aber ich mache keine tabellen in office ich verwende
keine office produkte ich will auch irgendwas was im browser funktioniert
so was hatten wir was hatten was haben die jetzt noch so angezeigt also das das könnte
tatsächlich ganz gescheit sein die haben ja gar keine gescheiten screenshots haben
die haben die in docker image oder sowas was man mal ausprobieren auch nicht
wie installiert man das versionen wird aktuell entwickelt ok wenn auch kein lipo office ich
habe zwar installiert aber wie gesagt ich verwende keine office produkte
so getting started haben die
er gibt mir einfach in fernischen docker container und gutes docker
ja der zeitren docker stack was das wieder mit 50 milliarden sachen
ok was was sagt denn self hosted das ist so eigentlich meines meine erste anlaufstelle
auf reddit wo ich wenn ich nachgucke was zu gibt home inventory system guck mal ich bin
ja der einzige der sowas sucht easy and simple phone app ist mir wurscht ok also vielleicht
sollte ich mir das doch noch mal angucken vielleicht soll ich mir das auch wenn das
alle empfehlen vielleicht soll ich mir das doch noch mal angucken was ist das denn es
klingt nach einer einkaufsliste erbierend moment das ist eine einkaufsliste ich wusste
gar nicht dass man in der einkaufsliste 2,7.000 github sterne kriegt aber warum nicht scheint
scheint ja scheint ja schon mal was gutes zu sein ja auch wieder die haben auch wieder
kassas doch screenshots das ich wollte erst sagen das schreit ja bootstrap aber doch nicht
so wirklich oder leute was für einen was für einen css fertig css gedöns hat er da
ist bestimmt nicht alles selbst gemacht kummi bären aber hat er eine demo public demo pizzer
teig excellent price history oder bist du aber ganz schön beschäftigt mit überlegt
euch mal ihr kauft eine pizza scannt die und dann müsst ihr noch den preis eintragen dass
das dass der preistracker sich aktualisiert er hat mal was zu tun wobei das bestimmt bestimmt
ganz gut geht mit mit mit barcodescanner und sowas aber da hast du ganz schön was zu tun
da hast du das ganz schön ganz schön was zu tun auch tasks da drin klasse jetzt es
wird bloß noch ein email klein ja jedes program braucht irgendwann auch mal ein email klein
equipment weil es hat ein notizprogramm drin ok die tanzen hier auf relativ vielen hochzeiten
würde ich sagen keck weh ach das ist für manuals ok omega lul die übertreiben sind
to do list kalender kalender to do list alle ich will einfach nur inventar management transfer
aber kann man barcodescan ok das ist mir auch so auch zu zu weiß nicht so hat das versucht
auf zu vielen hochzeiten zu tanzen irgendwie wie legt man denn überhaupt jetzt ein produkt
an ok so eine gurke so eine gurke excellent sogar mit bild preis history das musste ja
das musste ja von hand tracken das kriegt er bestimmt nicht über eine web api das musste
wahrscheinlich von hand tracken oder sagt man mal so vielleicht geht es in den usa vielleicht
haben wir in usa eine api in deutschland garantiert nicht ok wie lege ich denn wie lege ich denn
neue ist neues produkt an management master data products so ich will neues produkt anlegen
add ok esp 32 out msu so keck weh barcode habe ich nicht die folgen ok naja es wird
schon funktionieren das wird schon funktionieren da würde ich jetzt einfach einstellen das
ding ist keine ahnung hier irgendwo ja im kühlschrank also ich würde sagen schrank
eins ja aber das passt nicht so wirklich finde ich hier inventory inventory ok was empfehlen
sie sonst noch es gibt ein home assistant add-on dafür was macht das ja dynastix ok
leuchtet ein aber das ist auferkill für ich habe daheim ein paar teile und wenn das
include ist einfach nur als zeitbar das ist ja kein ding ob sich das lohnt also sie sagen
alle man soll snipet ausprobieren gibt davon in docker jetzt davon in docker dann mache
ich jetzt einfach mal start ich jetzt einfach mal nein ich jetzt hört mir auf mein exis
db ich werde im leben keine exis db nehmen ich werde auch kein excel spreadsheet nehmen
garantiert nicht so hier docker run
ich starte das jetzt einfach mal und dann gucken wir uns das an ob das was taugt
excel listo dann per makro in die exis db da können wir bestimmt noch ein paar schöne
schöne zwischenschritte einbauen das ganze dann erst noch mal über active sync outlook
synchronisieren und an example ab key you could use this was was will er von mir ab
hii
Minus minus E muss ich machen, environment, ja ist ja gut, docker, geh aus, ich muss das
minus E, äh, warte mal, wie geht das doch, docker, environment, variables, minus E, minus
minus N, ne doch, hier so, also was, app, key, gleich, so, was, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
was, ach, Moment, muss man das hinten dran schreiben, kann ich mir nicht ein fertiges
Startcommand, ups, ah, jetzt macht er was, ok, docker, ps, port 80, localhost, nein,
nein, ok, geht nicht, excellent, oder auch nicht, ja, so Container finde ich ja immer
geil, wenn die dann so gut funktionieren, meinste, der macht noch was, ne, der macht
nix mehr, der ist fertig, ok, anscheinend ist es doch nicht so einfach mit einfach starten
und gutes, kommen wir mal hier, einfach mal hier gucken, wie man das ausführen kann,
so seriös, ok, donc, was mache ich jetzt jetzt, basic, ok, so, ok, dann roundische
Exzellent, dann nehmen wir den da. Nehmen wir den da, der funktioniert.
Wow
Bitte, bitte noch längeren. Nein, ich will kein MySQL.
Guck mal, das hier, einfach mal, einfach starten. Kann man das nicht einfach starten?
Okay, dann nehmen wir dieses Docker Composting.
Wird kein Excess, im Leben wird es kein Excess.
Was haben wir hier alles? Ja, irgendwas, da kannst du... noch, noch ein Temp-Ordner, immer mehr Temp-Ordner.
DockerCompost.yml
Paste, ist ganz schön, in der Zeit hätte ich es ja von Hand installiert. Okay, your application url, also
1222x131, 8080, meinetwegen 8080, ist okay.
Blabla, secret password, huge, komm dir nicht drauf chat. So, snipe, secret password, 123456, secret password, 123456, so.
Top secret password ist das. Pass to MySQL data.
Ich würde sagen, eindeutig, slashcacw
Valid MySQL, perfekt, DockerCompost, oh, hab ich gerade installiert, sorry, warum nicht?
Hab ich einen Zapp übersehen?
17 Monate, alter, massive, danke schön für den Zapp.
Massive, 17 Monate, das ist ja schon richtig.
Was habe ich aus vergessen? Hab ich was übersehen?
Ah, hier, hier.
Slash
Lulwe, DockerCompost, ab.
Oh, Rusty, danke schön für den Zapp, vier Monate, big brain, high IQ subscription.
Oh, hab ich einen Doppelpunkt irgendwo gelöscht?
Oh, perfekt. Geht das jetzt?
Und scheint, localhost 880, da, da sind wir, oh no, but your relos, oh, ja, dann machen wir das doch.
Alles klar, create database, alles klar. Läuft es in einer VM? Ja, ja, Ubuntu sagt, also es sagt prinzipiell alles in einer VM, was 2D, 3D Beschleunigung braucht, also in Maßen geht das noch, aber gerade Ubuntu ist bekannt dafür, dass der Desktop
Kacke ist. Und, also gut, mittlerweile ist es ein ganz normaler Gnome, aber das läuft nicht sonderlich schnell in einer VM, weil die keine gescheite 3D Unterstützung haben.
Ja, das ist normal. Also du solltest auf jeden Fall in die Settings gehen und 3D Acceleration anschalten, sonst kannst du es komplett vergessen, aber Ubuntu ist bekannt dafür, dass das Kacke in VMs läuft.
Generell Gnome 3 ist in VMs nicht schön. KDE ist auch nicht viel besser, Xfce geht ein bisschen besser, aber am besten, ganz ehrlich, i3 und Dings hier, Mate geht glaube ich auch noch ganz gut.
Ja, Mint geht, aber nicht mit Cinnamon, sondern nur mit Mate glaube ich ist das. Mint geht ganz gut immer, ja, wenn du es richtig nimmst. So, was wollen die hier von mir? Die Fallen Länge, alles.
Default Currency, kann man das so? Mal gucken, ob man das checkt. Ja, mach mal. Was will der von mir? Ich will keine E-Mails. Ich will keine E-Mails.
Lass mich in Ruhe, ich will einfach mal Zeug eintragen. Alter, was willst du von mir?
So, E-Mail Domain.
Ja, also es ist auch ein Unterschied übrigens. Also i3 läuft so auch ganz gut, aber am besten läuft das mit dem Ding hier dabei. Im Hintergrund. Dann kannst du sogar sowas machen wie Faden zwischen den Desktops und sowas.
So, also jetzt habe ich den Kram jetzt gelesen. Wo würde ich denn da jetzt was eintragen von mir? Also sagen wir mal, ich möchte jetzt mal ein TT-Go-Board eintragen. Und ich möchte irgendwo eintragen, wo ich mein TT-Go-Board habe.
Nicht Titti, sondern TT-Go-Chat. Ich weiß jetzt schon was kommt, was gleich jemand tippt im Chat. Also was haben wir? New Asset ist das.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einem Accessory? Also mein Consumable ist klar. Ein Consumable ist was, was ich verbrauche. Wir haben einen Stream gemacht mit der VM Installation.
New Asset, New Accessory. Ich würde sagen, ich mache das im... Was ist denn da der Unterschied? Ein Asset ist irgendwann ein größeres Ding.
Nee, Kategorie kann ich gar nicht auswählen. Ja, dann nehme ich das hier. Also dann nehmen wir jetzt mal... Company brauchen wir nicht, brauchen wir nicht.
So, das sind ESP2 TT-Go. Testen wir mal. Kategorie. Machen wir mal irgendwie... So. So, Supplier. Brauche ich Arnold Manufactor erstmal vollkommen wurscht.
So, Location. Okay, Location. City? Country? Monkeys. Arabische Emirate. Ich würde da sowas reinschreiben wie Flur. Schrank 1, Alter.
Modellnummer, Ordernummer. Brauche ich nicht, brauche ich alles nicht. Gut, Quantity ist ganz gut. Davon habe ich 5. Save.
Das... Ich glaube, das kann ich verwenden. So, kann ich jetzt hier auch... Nee, Moment. Hier kann ich nicht suchen, aber hier kann ich suchen. Kann ich hier nach Flur suchen?
Ja. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich brauchbar. Ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich brauchbar. Sollen wir jetzt Checkout?
Jaja, der hier Checkout. Checkout. Jetzt sind es nur noch 4. Und wie geht man es wieder zurück? Kann man es wieder zurückgeben? Ach, hier. View assign. Ach, hier kann ich es zurückgeben oder so.
Okay, das ist eine Funktion, die brauche ich wirklich nicht. Lustig. Wie gebe ich das jetzt zurück? Export in Excel. Accept Assets.
Okay, das ist ein bisschen advanced für das, was ich brauche, ehrlich gesagt. Aber ich meine, es tut es. Assets? Was sind Components?
Components are items that are part of an asset. Ah, also wenn man was zusammengebautes hat. Okay, okay. Verstehe.
Ist das eine Shiny App? Nee. Also zumindest, ich glaube, damit kann ich das machen, was ich machen will. Damit wird man Felder anpassen können. Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo hier im Admin-Bereich oder so. Am liebsten würde ich den ganzen, hier Custom Fields, am liebsten würde ich den ganzen Mist rausschmeißen, den ich nicht brauche.
Ich würde am liebsten alles entfernen, was ich nicht brauche. Ich meine, ich brauche ja nichts.
Oh, guck mal, jetzt kann ich sogar sagen Check In. Jetzt gebe ich es wieder zurück. Excellent. Und jetzt ist es wieder 5. Okay, das ist gar nicht schlecht. Barcodes. Ja, aber das bringt mir jetzt erst mal nicht so viel.
Ich muss es wahrscheinlich erst mal vorhanden haben. Genau, dann würde ich dann Zeug antragen, dann würde ich dann noch irgendwie sagen, okay, dann habe ich noch irgendwie so das Company.
Das will ich zum Beispiel löschen. I do not have serial number, okay. So zum Beispiel Company, das brauche ich nicht. Das kann man doch bestimmt, das kann man doch dann bestimmt entfernen.
Oder auch, oder wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich, das ist wahrscheinlich Default in der Datenbank drinnen.
Ja, die Idee ist nicht schlecht. Also okay, ich glaube, das ist gar nicht so übel. Muss man mal angucken, was man da alles customisieren kann.
Ja, das schaue ich mir mal an. Siehste, deswegen sind so Docker Containers echt praktisch. Jetzt kann ich es einfach wieder wegschmeißen und weg ist alles.
Wunderbar. Keque. Oh Mann, wo habe ich das jetzt gespeichert?
Was macht er denn bei Volumes? Punkt Slash null W. Was genau macht er da, wenn ich das so eingegeben habe?
Der wird ja nicht wirklich null W machen. Darf er ja auch gar nicht als mein User.
Point FD null W. Gibt es nicht. Es juckt den überhaupt nicht, dass ich da null W eingegeben habe.
Kann man nicht bei bei Docker Containers irgendwie gucken, wo welches Verzeichnis der benutzt?
Ja, das kann auch sein, dass das jetzt verworfen wurde. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich hat er alles verworfen. Ja, denke ich auch. Gucken wir mal.
Ach, Moment. Das ist die Demo. Ach ach.
Nee, es ist noch da. Docker Volumes.
Nee, das meine ich nicht. Ich meine, wohin was gemapt ist. Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich das stoppe?
Und dann. Der wird das einfach intern gespeichert haben jetzt. Wenn ich jetzt sage hier daun und jetzt wieder ab, dann ist es weg.
Gehe ich mal von aus. Nee, immer noch da.
Jedoch, da fehlt der Doppelpunkt. Ich frage mich jetzt nur, was er gemacht hat ohne den Doppelpunkt.
Was macht er ohne den Doppelpunkt? Wohin speichert er das?
Interessant. Ja, wahrscheinlich intern.
Doch, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das taugt halbwegs. So für privaten Dings.
Wenn ich alles ausblende, dann mache ich das. Wirklich Leute, ich muss meinen ganzen Krämpel mal ein bisschen inventarisieren,
weil ich blicke nicht mehr durch. Ich habe überall Zeugs von Werkzeug bis Kleinkram bis Controller bis irgendwelche Sensor.
Und sei es hier nur so ein komisches Silikon Klebeband, wo ich mich öfters mal frage, wo es ist.
Ich bin mich da nicht mehr zurecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Was? 60131, ja. So, jetzt ist hier meine leichte LED-Leiste zuvor sich hin.
Ich habe gesehen, man kann übrigens auch einstellen, dass der jetzt nach 60 Minuten ausgeht.
Das ist eigentlich eine ziemlich coole Funktion.
Er stimmt, Docker löscht das gar nicht automatisch. So, so schaut es jetzt aus. Ich habe es jetzt gar nicht wieder umgestellt.
Excellent.
So Chat, ich gehe auf. Wie gesagt, war hier nur eine kurze Geschichte heute.
Eineinhalb Stunden.
Ich bin übelst müde. Ich war schon müde, als ich angefangen habe, als ich den Stream angemacht habe.
Dementsprechend haben wir heute auch nichts wirklich Sinnvolles gemacht. Einfach ein bisschen rumgekommen, ein bisschen geschwätzt.
Gut ist. Wunderbar.
Nein, nicht. Doch, ich bin müde. Ich muss jetzt auf. Was ist mit dem Friseur? Streamt der Friseur vielleicht?
Friseur. Vier Tage hat er wieder irgendwelche Weep Games gespielt.
Guck's euch an.
Die Hose ist aber auch tragwürdig knapp. Also die ist knapp in der Form, dass ich mir relativ sicher bin.
Sowas kann man nicht konstruieren. Vor allem nicht ohne, dass es ganz schön kneift hier. Na ja, gut.
Aber da geht es ja bei sowas nicht rum.
Ach, dann hat er jetzt ein Volumen gemacht und eingehangen mit Lulvee und sowas im Container. Na gut, das bringt ihm ja auch nichts.
Okay, Leute. Ich gehe auf. Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen wieder. Dann machen wir was Sinnvolles. Alles klar. Bis dann. Macht's gut. See you.